It's embarrassing,
it's a,
you know,
whether or not my son does well on the
baseball team and whether or not he is
able to hit,
um,
what worries me at night about the
world.
I don't know.
I don't sleep much,
so I spent a lot of time,
you know,
on line.
I'm reading news in the middle of the
night.
Um,
lately actually not so much seems,
seems very worrying for me.
Strangely.
It seems like a few years ago it was
much worse.
Uh,
maybe that was a,
you know,
now to be honest,
if you look@CNN.com,
you know,
nothing ever happened as far as I can
tell.
Uh,
so,
but you know,
there's,
there's more insidious things happening
with your scary,
I guess.
Um,
I don't stay up at night worrying about
global warming even though I think it's
a huge problem.
Um,
you know,
this is embarrassing.
I stay up at night worrying about
worrying about local stuff.
Yeah.
I'm sorry,
I should have something really deep to
say about that.